معنا من اسطنبول رامي عبده مدير المركز
الاوروبي لحقوق الانسان اهلا بك سيد رامي
الاورو متوسط لحقوق الانسان سيد رامي من
خلال متابعتك ل مرافعات الامس لجنوب
افريقيا انت كحقوق كيف تقيم الرد ومرافعه
الفريق القانوني الاسرائيلي
اليوم يعني بكل تاكيد الدفعات المثاره
اليوم هناك فجوه كبيره بين الدفعات
المثاره من الفريق القانوني الاسرائيلي
وما يجري على ارض الواقع مفردات ما يجري
على ارض الواقع تفند وتكذب كل الادعاءات
المثاره او الدفعات المثاره من الجانب
الاسرائيلي او الفريق القانوني الاسرائيلي
على عكس الفريق القانوني الجنوب افريقي
بالامس كان يقدم ادله دامغه وكل ادعاءاته
كان لها ما يثبتها من الواقع وبالعكس حتى
جنوب افريقيا كانت متحفظه كثيرا في
المصادر صحيح انها اعتمدت على مصادر
حقوقيه ومصادر اعلاميه ل لكن لم تقدم رقم
الا كان مصدر الامم المتحده بدءا من
الامين العام للامم المتحده ووكاله الامم
المتحده المعروفه مثل اليونيسيف وبرنامج
الغذاء العالمي ومنظمه الصحه العالميه
وبالتالي كل ما قدمته جنوب افريقيا كان له
ما يقابله من اسانيد على النقيد تماما
اسرائيل استخدمت الخطاب الذي تستخدمه
والذي كان متوقعا واعتقد انه جنوب افريقيا
اصلا بالامس الفريق القانوني الخاص فيها
فند مثل هذه الادعاءات بشكل مسبق واضح جدا
ان اسرائيل لعبت باتجاهين الاتجاه الاول
هو الطعن في صلاحيه المحكمه في النظر في
هذه القضيه او الطعن في الاختصاص القضائي
عبر القول انه الذي يحدث في غزه اليوم هو
ربما يقع ضمن اطار القانون الانساني
الدولي وبالتالي هناك اليات دوليه للقانون
الانساني الدولي ليس من بينها المحكمه او
محكمه العدل الدوليه وهو امر لا يقابل
حقيقه باتساق مع الحالات التي نظرت فيها
المحكمه قبل ذلك اي دليل طيب برايك الى ي
مدى ستتمكن اسرائيل
باقناع المحكمه بالدفع بمبرر الدفاع عن
النفس وهذا ما تردد اكثر من مره
اليوم يعني هذا لا وجه له حقيقه لانه اذا
نظرنا الى جريمه الاباده هناك ركنين
اساسيين في جريمه الاباده الركن المعنوي
او عندما نتحدث او الركن العقلي وهو القصد
الجنائي هل كانت اسرائيل لديها النيه في
اباده الشعب الفلسطيني هناك تصريح
لمسؤولين الاسرائيليين من كل المستويات
اسرائيل واضح جدا انها كانت تحاول ان تقول
انه هذا تصريحات اخرجت من سياق او زله
لسان لكن واضح جدا انه كما قلنا الفريق
الجنوب افريقي رد بالامس عبر عدد كبير من
التصريحات من قلب او بدءا من راس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ومجلس الحرب الفريق
الاسرائيلي قال او ادعى او حاول ان يقول
انه هذه التصريحات ليست من جوهر الحكومه
او صانع القرار في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وبالتالي كان جنوب افريقيا بالامس الفريق
الخاص فيها بالامس تحدث عن يعني شهادات
وتصريحات للفريق او لمستوى يقع او يعمل
داخل مجلس الحرب الامر الاخر او الاتجاه
الاخر هو الركن المادي والركن المادي
يتحدث بشكل واضح عن جرائم اسرائيليه
ارتكبت سواء على عمليه صعيد عمليات القتل
الجماعي المنظم او عمليات استهداف اسس
الحياه في غزه وهذه واضحه للعيال لا يمكن
انكارها وبالتالي الروايه الاسرائيليه لن
تستطيع ان تجابه مثل هذه الحقائق وايضا
عمليات التهجير التي مورست بشكل فاضح حاول
الفريق القانوني الاسرائيلي ان يقول ان ما
يحدث ليس تهجير وانما نقل للسكان من منطقه
الى اخرى ولكن تقارير الامم المتحده
وتصريحات الساسه الاسرائيليين الذين
يقولون اننا لن نسمح بعوده السكان في جنوب
غزه الى الشمال رغم تقريبا انتهاء
العمليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في الشمال
الا بعوده الاسرى الاسرائيليين وبالتالي
استخدامهم كورقه مساومه الموقف القانوني
الاسرائيلي حقا وجدا ضعيف وما تستخدمه
اسرائيل هو امتداد لاساليب الدعائيه التي
استخدمتها في تبرير جرائمها بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني منذ عام 48 شكرا جزيلا لك رامي
عبده مدير المركز الاورو متوسطي لحقوق
الانسان من اسطنبول